but yeah I think you're absolutely right
you know like feminism turns women and
it's why I call it toxic feminism so
toxic feminism got to be clear turns
women into terrible versions of men um
they're told to you know be disagreeable
to climb the corporate ladder to get
more degrees to be bossy and um what's
the other one that you know they tell
women to do where it's like the you know
they want like witty banter but like
they but like women's version of w of
witty banter sucks like it's not like
men's version you know where we sort of
bust each other's chops it's like really
you know sort of thing yeah so yeah it
does turn them into sort of terrible
versions of um men but it is what it is
I thankfully there are still some
feminine women out there that understand
you know these realities but the problem
is is they usually don't get to the
understanding part until they're older
you know well yeah until they're Pastor
Prime and they realize hang on a second
maybe I'm 37 I need to re-evaluate why
things haven't gone the way that I
thought they would go uh let me take a
look out there and they find something
or they start diving down these rabbit
holes that explain to them you know like
the bestselling book out there for women
is why men love the second
best-selling book that that woman wrote
was why men marry and they've
sold millions of copies of this steaming
pile of dog that women consume and
they're convinced to again you know be
dis be disagreeable uh not not be not be
friendly not you know take on pink jobs
and let him do blue jobs you know it is
what it is well yeah I mean with what
you said about when feminism do know I
always use this term to people and
theyve start some people CAU it on I
think more people need to say this
feminism turns women into vindictive
men in terms of the symbol and what I
mean by that is they are very vindictive
all the boss babes I don't care who they
are they always have a vindictive nature
to them riddled with Envy yeah the
effectively are dious that's why they're
so like I don't care what anyone say if
you meet a man with a Napoleon complex
or has clearly been castrated
psychologically or physically to make up
for it to become extremely freaking
hostile or have a extreme
nature and then you have the man part as
well and that's why I always laugh that
people say oh these women are so
masculine no no no no no no they're not
masculine they're
unfeminine yeah they're unfeminine and
because so many men have become more
feminine or adopted softer traits are
lower te uh become less so you know
women can become more there was a um
here let me share one quick thing here
uh with you because I've got uh got a
few other people waiting here but a
buddy of mine that's in the marketing
space um and I want to make a video
about this I I have to get the original
post but this is the typical thing that
goes on he said this stuff is driving me
bonkers so many white Knights pandering
in the comments the white dude comment
you know
bracket quotation is so Brazen how does
anyone put up with that racism and
sexism on full display just because
there's a majority of women in marketing
doesn't mean that they're on the
leadership board so this so this
chick some some of the gals hate the
word chick but I don't care it's in my
vocabulary forever so this chick goes
spoiler spoiler alert and she's
complaining AI is based So based that
when the female quoten search for AI the
most influential person is advertised is
listed six men and only one woman worst
ai's visual embodiment of the results
ended up being this white guy this white
guy he's not real but based AI is and
she goes on you know complaining about
why there aren't women to blah blah blah
blah blah it's like you know there's
always these you know complaints about
why the most influential person in
marketing or something like that isn't a
woman but there's no push to get woman
on garbage trucks and oil rigs and
Roofing jobs and coal mines it's just
this yeah I agree I agree
that's why I don't buy the feminist BS
and to I've been finding the feminist
cause for like 12 years and this is what
always makes me laugh that um when women
talk about oh these women are so
masculine like no no no no you're not
one of the traits of masculinity is
stoicism yeah and you are the opposite
to stoic so like cut that BS strength is
another big part of masculinity which
they completely Miss as well well yeah
and this what makes me laugh is like if
you look at the so-called most masculine
women in the truest sense they are all
known as
tomboys and and I don't care what anyone
says a tomboy once you've had it I you
cannot go back in some ways I regard it
as like a forbidden fruit for B men
because once you experience it
your mind is like open up you're like oh
my God this is so refreshing because
they maintain much of the femininity
aspect but they end up removing the
so-called negative aspects of the
femininity in question yeah I just I
just have nothing for time tomboy man
I'm I'm all femin girls no no don't get
wrong I love a feminine woman but my God
it is refreshing to deal with like
someone who's more of a tomboy or a girl
who's been raised but around a male
environment yeah oh you know I'll say
this um I've I've dated women that are
like that over a longterm basis and
they're they seem fun at first but
they're not over long-term basis they
just drive you nuts I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the fulllength podcast you
can find that over here that clips from
if you're new to the channel make sure
you hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out